До повномасштабного вторгнення РФ Наталія Сіромаха жила і працювала в Харкові.
Там досі залишаються її колеги - програмісти і розробники програмного забезпечення.
Через війну Наталія перебралася до польського Кракова й тепер працює дистанційно.
Щодня перед роботою жінка зв'язується з колегами з України, аби дізнатися, як у них справи.
Ми всі намагаємося викладатися на повну.
Ми розуміємо, що повинні працювати не покладаючи рук, щоб досягати успіху й підтримувати свою державу.
Хочу показати вам нашого кращого друга цими днями.
У мене теж такий є!
У мене нині немає світла. Але працює генератор, працює "старлінк".
У нас усіх також була можливість прийти в офіс, підзарядити наші пристрої.
Тож я би сказав, що ми анітрохи не втратили в продуктивності.
Є деякі проблеми з електрикою і водою в Києві, наприклад, у мене вдома.
Але в офісі проблем немає. Тому сьогодні і напередодні всі прийшли в офіс.
Тут і світло, і кава є. Тож ми працюємо, ми незламні й сильні, як і всі українці.
Так Харків виглядав на початку березня, невдовзі після перших російських обстрілів.
Чимало районів міста досі без світла й мобільного зв'язку.
Деякі співробітники телекомунікаційних компаній працюють з-за кордону, але роблять усе можливе,
аби люди в Харкові мали зв'язок та інтернет.
Основна проблема в нас на сьогоднішній день - це електрика і стільниковий зв'язок.
Не завжди буває зв'язок з нашими співробітниками, тому що більшість людей працюють у Харкові,
і не завжди з ними можна зв'язатися.
Алла Стручева нині в Польщі, але тричі приїжджала до Харкова, щоб допомагати.
Під час своєї першої поїздки жінка побачила, що росіяни зробили з її будинком.
Це відео зняте в травні цьогоріч, в оселі Алли на околиці Харкова.
Жінка повернулася за кілька місяців. Тоді російські війська вже відступили від Харкова.
Утім, від будинку Алли залишилося саме згарище.
Її колеги нині мають чимало роботи. Треба лагодити пошкоджені інтернет-кабелі.
Через відсутність електрики часто працюють у темряві, зі звичайними ліхтариками.
Інтернет - це зв'язок із зовнішнім світом.
Для жителів Харкова і компаній, які працюють у місті, доступ до мережі критично важливий.
Захисні каски й бронежилети тепер стали для майстрів невід'ємним елементом спорядження.
До війни ІТ-сектор в Україні процвітав. У галузі працювали понад 250 тисяч осіб.
Навіть цього року, попри війну, експорт комп'ютерних послуг
за десять місяців зріс на десять відсотків порівняно з попереднім роком.
Українські лікарні - одні з тих, хто регулярно отримує допомогу від ІТ-сектора.
Ми багато інвестуємо і передаємо гроші на захист нашої держави.
У Харкові айтішники задонатили більше мільярда гривень. І ми продовжуємо це робити.
У Кракові розробниця програмного забезпечення Наталія Сіромаха знайшла житло,
її діти ходять до місцевої школи і вивчають польську мову.
Утім, вони досі почуваються біженцями.
Син не виказував багато емоцій. Я бачила, як він умить подорослішав.
Для доньки це був великий стрес. Вона весь час питала: "Чому, чому? Що ми зробили поганого?
Чому я все втратила? Чому мої друзі більше не поруч?"
Ми всі нині - наче равлики. У равлика завжди з собою його дім, просто на спині.
У нас завжди з собою частинка України, Харкова.
У мене вона завжди при собі. Хоча я тут, у Польщі, думками я в Харкові.
Я досі в Україні.